-New York City, baby!
[ Cheers and applause ]
My name is Mike.
I'm in my 40s.
Some of you might be younger
so I'll tell you what it's lik
to be in your 40s.
[ Laughter ]
Whether I lift weights
or get drunk,
my body feels about the same
the next day.
I'm just achy and sore,
questioning all of
my life choices.
[ Laughter ]
My father gave me
some very bad advice growing up,
but it's gonna sound like
good advice when I say it.
But now that I'm in my 40s
I know it's bad.
This was the advice.
He said, "Michael,
always give 100%."
He said, "You can't go wrong
if you always give 100%."
That, my friends, is false
[ Laughter ]
If you give 100% at all times,
you will end up
in a mental institution.
[ Laughter ]
But you have to try sometimes.
So what I do now is,
when I walk into a situation
I check my cellphone.
Whatever percentage
my battery is at...
[ Laughter and applause ]
...that's how much effort
I give.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Tonight, they were like, "Mike
this crowd deserves 100%."
I said,
"37% is what they're gonna get."
[ Laughter and applause ]
"Unless somebody has a charger."
[ Laughter ]
I'm not married.
There's a lot of lies floating
around out there about marriage.
One is that marriage is 50/50.
I find that to be
not true at all.
The marriages that last
are never 50/50.
are a combination
of two types of people.
One person who is boring..
[ Laughter ]
...with another person
who is crazy.
[ Laughter ]
Boring and crazy is the only
combination that seems to work
I've done the math on this
Two borings don't work.
They'll cheat on each other.
Not enough excitement.
Two crazies don't work
'cause that's the show "Cops."
[ Laughter ]
Have you ever seen
the show "Cops"?
I've been through
a lot of breakups.
And when I break up
with a woman, never pleasant
I like to do it at a restaurant.
[ Laughter ]
'Cause I feel like
it's a public place
and she will not cause a scene
[ Laughter ]
But can I share a secret
with you guys?
The women of today will yell
at you right in a restaurant
[ Laughter ]
So you know what I do?
I take her
to a Chinese restaurant.
[ Laughter ]
That way if she yells at me,
it just seems like
she's working at the restaurant.
[ Laughter and applause ]
I'm trying to stay in shape.
I started doing hot yoga
last spring.
And one of the benefits
of doing hot yoga in New Yor
is that you get to carry a small
mat around the city with you
And I like that,
'cause my friends are dumb
They're like,
"Are you doing yoga?"
I'm like, "This? No.
I like to engage people
in tiny wrestling matches
all over town."
[ Laughter ]
That's how I work out now.
I start a confrontation.
I roll out the mat.
[ Laughter ]
I wave on the challenge.
I'm like, "Bring it, dawg!
Let's solve it in this
2 by 1 by 2 by 1-inch spac
that I carry around with m
for aggressive reasons."
[ Laughter ]
I complain about hot yoga
being too hot.
I'm one of those guys.
My friends are like,
"Mike, why don't you just
go to regular yoga?"
I'm like, "No, I like hot yoga
I like hot yoga because
you're sweating so much,
no one can tell
that you're crying."
[ Laughter ]
They're like,
"Mike, are you chanting?"
I'm like, "I am weeping."
[ Laughter ]
I told the instructor
it was too hot.
It's supposed to be 90 minutes
105 degrees,
but it feels like 140.
That's what I said.
She said,
"The seasons are changing.
We kind of have to adjust
to the seasons."
I'm like, "Do you know
how buildings work?"
[ Laughter ]
"You control the weather
on the inside of a building.
That's why it's different
from the outside of a building
Otherwise,
we would not need buildings.
We would just
do everything outside."
[ Laughter ]
She's like, "But don't you fee
better after it's over?"
I'm like, "I feel better the way
that someone feels better
after they've survived
a car accident."
[ Laughter ]
"I feel better that I'm alive.
But I don't feel better than i
I never would have come here."
[ Laughter ]
She's like,
"But you're losing weight.
Aren't you happy
that you're losing weight?
I'm like, "Am I losing weight?
I don't feel like
I'm losing weight.
I feel like I'm evaporating.
[ Laughter ]
"Feel like that's happening.
I feel like there's
a cloud outside
that looks exactly like me
Fat, white, and sad."
[ Laughter ]
You guys are amazing.
Thank you so much!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-How's it going, dude?
-It's good.
-Mike Vecchione!
[ Cheers and applause ]
For more,
visit mikevecchione.com.